people still rock the bongos gotta
respect that you know it's like driving
a manual car I never was a bong guy it's
too heavy man I got [ __ ] to do man I
can't oh that just peeled down or the
dab thing that I got friends in Colorado
California now the first time I ever did
wet [ __ ] this is pretty embarrassing
story but my I didn't know what it was
you know I just pulled it like it was a
big old bong rip and like everybody
special
oh you know I need you instantly no you
just did something you shouldn't have
oh and lay off [ __ ] man so I sat down
and after a couple minutes I just
started getting really cold and clammy I
was like yep I'm gonna puke so when I
was like I [ __ ] this guy so I puked
right in his sink I was like dude I got
to go home I feel like dog [ __ ] now and
I'm pretty sure I'm dying so we live in
this apartment I was like hey went out
the door and turned the corner to go
down the hallway to mine and it was
full-on vertigo like the hall every time
I took a step the hall we got twice as
long this is [ __ ] up my wife was out
of the country I work at the time I was
like I remember I was sitting down in
the hallway just like trying to get my
[ __ ] together man because I thought I
was having a [ __ ] heart attack it was
just like pow sweating and I remember
this voice saying get up you stupid
junkie [ __ ] before somebody comes out
here and sees you you know sitting in
the hallway like a dumbass and I managed
to like pop out of it and as soon as I
got back to my place and sit down on the
couch everything was fine
I don't nobody needs to be that stone
you know that fast I'm sorry